- Hi, everyone.
I'm Maurice Samuels, the director
of the Yale Program for
the Study of Antisemitism.
And I'm really happy to
welcome you here today
to our Benjamin and Barbara
Zucker Lecture Series.
Today's speaker, Mark Oppenheimer,
is the author of five books,
including "Knocking on Heaven's Door:
"American Religion in the
Age of Counterculture,"
which was based on his 2003 dissertation
in Yale's Religious Studies Department,
winner of that year's Porter Prize.
He was the religion columnist
for "The New York Times""
from 2010 to 2016,
and has written for "The
New York Times Magazine,"
"GQ," "Mother Jones," "The Nation"
and "The Atlantic,"
among other publications.
The host of "Tablet Magazine's"
podcast "Unorthodox,"
Oppenheimer has taught
at Stanford, Wellesley
and Yale, where since 2006,
he has directed the Yale
Journalism Initiative.
He lives with his family
in New Haven, Connecticut,
and currently teaches Daily Themes
in the English Department at Yale.
Last October, he published his new book,
"Squirrel Hill: The Tree
of Life Synagogue Shooting
"and the Soul of a Neighborhood,"
which he researched with funding
from our program.
And that is also the
title of his talk today.
So let me just say a word about
how things are gonna work.
Mark will speak for about 30 minutes,
and then we'll have about 20
to 25 minutes of questions
from the audience.
So please submit your questions
using the Q and A function
at the bottom of your screen.
Don't raise your hand
because we can't see you.
Now, (laughs) please join me
in welcoming Mark Oppenheimer.
- Maurice, thank you so much.
It's a great honor to be here.
And I would, first of all,
just very quickly like to thank
the Yale Program for the
Study of Antisemitism
for funding this project, in part,
and now for having me back
to talk to all of you about it,
and Maurice and Inessa Laskova
at the department, at the program.
I also wanna thank the Zucker
family for having endowed
this lecture series that's
having me here today.
As it happens, I have a history
with Ben Zucker because he,
among other things, in
addition to being himself
the author of some very fine books,
he is a jeweler who, years ago,
provided the setting
for the engagement ring
that I gave my wife.
And so far, the marriage has lasted,
so I figure, it all worked out well,
all's well that ends well.
So I haven't seen him in a while,
but it's good to be here,
and I hope he's here today.
I actually know that he tried to reach out
to me yesterday, and I
wasn't able to connect,
but it's good to be back with him
in that sense.
So I wanna say a little bit today
about the book,
and then I'm going to read
two pages from it.
Then I'm gonna share about
a dozen photographs from it
because it is a fairly
richly illustrated book,
which was very important to me.
And then I'm gonna read
one or two more pages.
And all told, that's gonna take
about 1/2 an hour, at most.
And then I really wanna leave ample time
for all of your questions,
because I think that's,
for me, certainly, (audio cuts out) part.
I've heard myself talk a lot
over the past few months,
and I haven't heard
from most of you at all.
And I think every time I speak,
I get new questions and new provocations
and people who enrich my own
thinking about this topic
along the way.
So let me first tell you where I was
on October 27th, 2018, in the morning,
which was the morning
of the deadliest antisemitic attack
in American history,
when 11 Jews were killed
inside the Tree of Life
Synagogue building,
out of the 22 people
who were inside the building that day.
So there were 22 people,
1/2 of whom did not make it out alive.
It was
a cold October morning
in Newton, Massachusetts,
where I was with my daughter,
my eldest daughter.
She had been invited to the bat mitzvah
of a summer camp friend of hers.
And so we were up at Temple Emanuel
in Newton, Massachusetts, two hours or so
from our home in New Haven.
We were inside synagogue all morning,
and so we did not
have technology with us.
We don't bring phones into
synagogue on the Sabbath,
in our family.
And I assume that because
there were hundreds
of people inside the building,
and it's not an extremely
religious congregation,
there were certainly people
there who had their phones out
at some point and probably knew
what was happening in Pittsburgh,
but if so, they didn't tell us,
and Rebecca and I didn't know.
When we got back out to my car,
in the parking lot, at
about one in the afternoon,
I did open up my phone
to see if my wife had reached us,
and I had all these text
messages from people,
saying, "Are you going to Pittsburgh?
"What's do you know about Pittsburgh?
"Can you find out more about Pittsburgh?"
And I thought, why are all these people
texting me about Pittsburgh?
So then I navigated over to my news app
and I saw what had happened.
And I must have looked
very, very stricken,
because my daughter Rebecca said to me,
she said, "Dad, is everything okay?"
And I said, "Well, no."
I said, "There's been a shooting,
"and some Jews are dead in Squirrel Hill."
And Rebecca said, "Squirrel Hill?
"Isn't that where we're from?"
And I said, "Well, in a sense, yes."
Because what she understood,
even though she herself is from New Haven
and I am from Springfield, Massachusetts,
she knew that her grandpa, my dad,
was from Squirrel Hill.
And I think she may even have known
from family lore that he
was the third generation
to be from the Squirrel Hill neighborhood
of Pittsburgh, and the fifth generation
to be from Pittsburgh, in fact.
So the Oppenheimers got to Pittsburgh
in the 1840s, and were in other parts,
slightly western parts of the city,
for two generations.
And then as soon as
Squirrel Hill was developed,
around the time of World War I,
they settled in Squirrel Hill
and had been there ever since.
So it was the family and
is the family homeland.
It's where her people are from.
So we were very, very, very torn apart.
And over the coming days,
I thought a lot about what it meant
to be from this neighborhood.
And increasingly, my mind kept going
to the neighborhood itself,
because although there
have been very good books
about the perpetrators
of antisemitic attacks
and of mass terror, indeed,
and mass shootings of which
there have been hundreds
in the United States
since Columbine in 1999,
what I realized I didn't
know enough about,
and what I immediately got curious about
as a journalist and a scholar,
was not the mind of the killer,
which I wasn't really interested
in spending time researching,
for obvious reasons.
And, indeed, it wasn't even the 11
who had been killed, who I'm
sure were beautiful souls,
each of whom might deserve
a book of their own.
But what I kept coming back to,
given my own preexisting interest,
was the question of the neighborhood,
because I knew Squirrel Hill history
and I knew that it was,
arguably, the oldest,
most stable Jewish neighborhood
in American history,
which is something we
can talk about later.
It had been substantively Jewish,
about 1/3, give or take,
consistently for 100 years,
from the time of World War I
until the present, so a century exactly.
And that's not something you could say
of any other neighborhood
in the United States.
It had always been a neighborhood
relatively free of antisemitism,
even though Jews had been a minority.
So it has always been Gentile majority,
and yet it's been a place
where Jews have felt safe.
And Pittsburgh, indeed, has been a place
relatively free of antisemitism.
So the irony that the
deadliest antisemitic attack
would come to Squirrel Hill
was not lost on me.
And I got very, very interested
in how the neighborhood,
in part, the neighborhood's
religious congregations,
because there are many Jewish synagogues
in Squirrel Hill and also
other houses of worship,
but really the neighborhood more broadly
was going to cope.
What would it mean to a neighborhood?
So armed with this question,
a terrible metaphor, armed,
but with this question, let's say,
I began going to Pittsburgh
the month after the shooting, in November.
Within a few weeks, I
had made my first trip,
and I ended up going 32 times
and interviewing about 250 people
over 18 months.
And I stopped reporting
just as COVID was
descending across the land
in March of 2020,
though that was entirely coincidental.
I had planned for several months
that March would be
about my stopping point
because I'd be coming up on 18 months,
and I really had more
than enough interviews
and reporting already,
and I had planned already
to stop about then.
So with these hundreds of interviews
and these several dozen trips,
I wrote this book that's really about
the concentric circles of people
affected by a tragedy,
that in the urb of a neighborhood
and in the kind of grid of life
of a neighborhood that's
walkable, bikeable,
that has people naturally
colliding into each other
because of commerce, because
of religious worship,
because of public institutions
like schools and post office
and supermarkets and so forth and so on.
The public library, all of this,
Squirrel Hill has all these things.
It's a kind of urban shtetl,
a kind of idyllic village.
What would that mean
for how people reacted to grief?
And the book that I wrote
is a kind of patchwork
of portraits of the people
who become relevant
outside of the scope
of the national media,
and even sometimes outside the scope
of the archivists and historians who come,
and naturally and for good reason,
gravitate toward families of the victims,
the survivors, clergy people,
people who have a kind of official status.
I was not as interested in people
with official status.
So what I'd like to do now is read to you,
again, just two pages, and
then I wanna take you through
some photographs, and then
we'll read another bit more.
The two pages that I wanna read to you
are from the prologue to the book.
And it's where I learned the story
of a woman named Tammy Hepps,
who becomes something of a
through line through the book.
She's a Harvard graduate,
about 40 years old
when this all happens.
Grew up outside Philadelphia,
in Cherry Hill, New Jersey,
but had migrated to Pittsburgh
in recent years
because she was an amateur genealogist
whose grandparents had
been from Homestead,
which is right across the river,
a steel town outside of Pittsburgh.
And she was doing a lot
of genealogical research.
So she'd become very embedded
in Pittsburgh's Jewish community.
She had moved to Squirrel Hill.
She'd been there the
better part of a decade.
And in the 24 hours after the killing,
really the 48 hours,
72 hours, she was everywhere.
She was at the Jewish Community Center
consoling someone who had lost her husband
in the shooting.
She was part of a group of
members of Bend the Arc,
a progressive Jewish organization,
that drafted a letter
asking that Donald Trump
not come to visit.
She was saying psalms, Tehillim,
outside of Tree of Life Synagogue
while the bodies were still inside.
Because a Jewish tradition
is that when keeping guard
over dead bodies, you recite psalms.
She had done that, and
finally, completely wiped out,
she is trudging home
on Sunday afternoon.
And this is what happens to her.
So have a listen for about three minutes.
Just after 2:30,
she turned onto Murray Avenue
and a truck pulled up in front of her.
On the side of it
were painted three curious words,
Crosses for Losses
As Tammy Hepps remembered it,
she looked into the truck
and saw a pile of crosses
in the back, Christian crosses.
They were all white,
and on a quick count,
she decided there were 11 of them.
As soon as she grasped
what she was seeing,
she was incensed.
"I thought to myself," Hepps recalled,
"you have got to be kidding me."
And I looked around, and
no one else was there.
And I thought, if I have to be the one
to tell this man he can't put crosses
on the synagogue property,
I will be the one to tell him.
Hepps had no idea who this guy was,
with this kind of nerve.
As she was figuring
out what to say to him,
trying to keep her cool,
she saw on the front seat of his truck
a pile of wooden six-pointed stars.
She was relieved.
I thought, okay,
what will happen is he'll
put the Stars of David
on the fronts of the crosses,
and it will be okay.
Greg Zanis got out on the
driver's side of the truck
and approached Tammy Hepps.
She looked him up and down.
He was tired, unshaven, old.
What was he doing here?
Where did he come from?
Then she looked down and saw his hands,
and it was as if something became clear.
I saw his hands were covered
in white paint, Hepps remembered.
It's like he painted
these things overnight
and didn't even have
time to wash his hands.
He told me his intention.
He said to me, "I made these things,
"got in a truck and drove nine hours.
"I've been driving the whole time.
"I don't even know the names
of the people who died.
"I have to write their
names on the stars."
And then Hepps knew what she had to do.
Her mother had emailed
her the names of the dead
just that morning, so she
had the names on her phone:
Joyce Fienberg, Richard Gottfried,
Rose Mallinger, Jerry Rabinowitz,
Cecil Rosenthal, David Rosenthal,
Bernice Simon, Sylvan Simon,
Daniel Stein, Melvin Wax, Irv Younger.
"I brought up this list," she recalled,
"and he said to me,
"'Can you please write the
names in my notebook?'"
And as he handed me a
pen and his notebook,
I was shaking as I copied the names down
so he could write them on the stars.
When Hepps had written down all 11 names,
she gave Zanis' notebook back to him.
And now she had a question for him.
I said to him, "Why do you do this?"
And he said that there'd been gun violence
in his family, and this was his response.
He said, "You remember Parkland?
"I did that one.
"Remember Columbine?
"I did that one, too."
It had never occurred
to me, Hepps told me,
that it was one person who had made it
his life's work to drive
around the country and do this.
And at that moment, I realized that we
were just another one on the list.
So that's Tammy Hepps' encounter
with Greg Zanis, whose
nonprofit organization,
Crosses for Losses,
which was a nonprofit
of one, it was just him,
traveled around the country constantly,
putting up these white crosses
at the sites of mass tragedy.
And again, that's just a kind of example
of the people who arrive and create,
who add color
and create the effect and the mood
in the aftermath of a mass killing.
And I wanna show you some pictures now.
So here, you can see the cover
of my book.
And it actually didn't occur to me
when I first saw it,
and it's a beautiful cover,
how symbolically interesting
it was if read as a text.
What you see is the scene
outside Tree of Life
about 48 hours after the killing.
More than 48, 'cause it was the evening.
And you see that already,
it's become a shrine,
a memorial to the dead.
But what's interesting here is the way
that it's become an interfaith memorial,
because the candles that you see,
the little tea candles, are, of course,
a Jewish sign of mourning, right?
Jews light these candles on Yahrzeit
and on the anniversaries
of people's deaths.
We, of course, also use, Jews, ritually,
to bring in the Sabbath, to
leave the Sabbath and so forth.
So candles are very liturgically Jewish.
Flowers are not.
Flowers, actually, are
a part of the American
and Christian idioms.
And, of course, Christians
will bring flowers
to gravesides, which
Jews will typically not.
They'll bring candles
or they'll bring stones.
We put stones on graves.
But typically not flowers, except insofar
as in America, that's something people do.
But already, you can see
that you have a kind of Jewish semiotics
and a Christian semiotics, tropes of both
of those communities coming together
in this very, very beautiful
makeshift kind of memorial garden
outside of Tree of Life
within just a couple days.
This is Greg Zanis, the
one I just talked about.
He put millions of miles
on a whole series of pickup trucks
that he drove into the ground
from 1995 or six, when he first made
some crosses for a woman
in his grief support group
who had lost her son.
Zanis had lost his father-in-law,
as I recall.
And then Columbine
happened a few years later,
and he started driving around the country,
and he went to every
mass killing he could.
Also, he went to the sites
of natural disasters.
He went to the sites of people
who had been killed in
tornadoes, hurricanes,
huge traffic fatalities, things like that.
And he was an Evangelical
Christian himself,
but he always tried to
be culturally sensitive.
He would do things like
put the Star of David
on the front of the cross if he knew
that the victim was Jewish.
He also would put a crescent moon
if he knew that the victim was Muslim.
He knew appropriate symbols for Sikhs
and Baha'i and Hindu and Shinto.
He even had a symbol,
and I forget what it was,
if he heard that the victim was an atheist
or an agnostic.
So he was very, very sensitive,
and he became a kind of one-man emissary
of interfaith deathcraft, if you will.
He himself died in December of 2020,
and you could find his obituary
in "The New York Times."
I was very interested in the way
that visual culture was
shaped by the aftermath
of a mass killing.
Everywhere you go,
whether it was the bombing
in Boston or whether it's
Parkland or whatever,
there ends up becoming
something that's this kind
of visual representation
by mutual mass agreement.
And in Pittsburgh, it was this symbol,
which most of you have seen.
And it was created
by a graphic designer named Tim Hindes,
not spelled like Heinz
ketchup, which is, of course,
one of the great Pittsburgh companies.
It's spelled H-I-N-D-E-S.
And he was a lapsed Lutheran, Gentile,
German American graphic designer
who lived in the south
suburbs of Pittsburgh.
Didn't know anyone at Tree of Life.
Not kind of involved in interfaith work
or the Jewish community.
Just a kind of Christian American dude
who wanted to do something to help.
And he's driving home,
listening to this on the radio.
He happened to be in
Pittsburgh that morning
when it happened.
All the sudden, he fires up his Macintosh
and thinks, as a graphic
designer, what can I do?
And he wants to create
something that represents
the way that Pittsburgh embraces its Jews.
So he thinks well, what's Pittsburgh?
And he thinks what's more Pittsburgh
than the Pittsburgh Steelers?
So he takes the logo of
the Pittsburgh Steelers,
and then he replaces
the yellow hypocycloid
at the top, that's what
those shapes are called,
as I learned in reporting this book,
he replaces it with a yellow Star of David
to kind of mash up the
Pittsburghery and the Jewry.
And then he replaces the word Steelers
with the words Stronger Than Hate,
playing on Boston Strong, Orlando Strong
and other terms you hear
and the catchphrases
in the aftermath of a mass killing.
He puts it on Facebook.
Within a few hours, it's
gone around the world
a trillion times or so.
The next day at the Steelers game,
people are holding up posters
with this logo on them.
The Steelers end up
wearing it on their cleats.
You can find it on babies' onesies.
You can find it on yarmulkes.
And perhaps most movingly, it ends up
being posted in the windows of storefronts
throughout Squirrel Hill,
all along the Forbes and
Murray commercial corridor.
And again, created by somebody not Jewish,
but lives 10 to 20 miles
from the site of the killing,
and it ends up kind of becoming
this Jewish, but also Jewish Pittsburgh,
interfaith, intercommunal symbol.
Another one of those iconic symbols
was the headline of the
"Pittsburgh Post-Gazette"
on the Friday after the killings.
Now, keep in mind, the 11 victims
who were from three
different congregations
that were housed at the
Tree of Life building
were buried over four days.
So there were 11 funerals
over four days in a neighborhood
less than three square miles.
Constant crowds and traffic snarls
and people trying to
get from place to place.
And just a neighborhood
suffused with grief.
This headline ran on the last day
of the funerals, Friday morning.
And what's so interesting
is David Shribman,
now retired, but who
was the editor-in-chief
of the "Post-Gazette,"
he had this idea to run the Hebrew
for the first line of the Kaddish,
the mourner's prayer that Jews say,
the first line being
(speaking in a foreign language)
hallowed and exalted be the name.
Be the great name, right?
And he didn't know how
to spell it in Hebrew.
And he called his rabbi
at a different temple,
not Tree of Life.
He's a member of Temple Sinai.
And Rabbi Gibson sent him the text
in an email.
So Shribman then, as I learned,
took it to his graphic designer,
his chief designer at the "Post-Gazette,"
and said, "Make a headline out of this."
And she said, "We actually don't have
"a Hebrew font that big.
"We don't have a Hebrew headline typeface
"at the 'Post-Gazette.'"
So they had to kind of create it
from scratch right there.
They got it up.
And the next day, Friday morning,
it hit people's doorsteps and newsstands,
and people just broke into tears.
It was so beautiful, so perfect,
so completely iconic.
Another one of those images
that I think will
survive, this one forever,
quite literally, is the window
of the Starbucks at the
corner of Forbes and Shady,
the busier of the two Starbucks
in Squirrel Hill.
The lapsed Presbyterian Starbucks manager,
Melissa Lysaght, wanted to do something
for her heavily Jewish clientele,
who she knew were grieving.
So she called her Roman Catholic friend
Nicole Flannery and said,
"Can you do something
Jewish for the windows?"
Nicole Flannery's a local artist.
So Flannery connected
with an Orthodox Jewish man
and asked him for advice on what to do.
And he gave her the idea
for the Star of David,
the tree life and the dove.
And then he helped her with the words
(speaking in a foreign language)
love, kindness and hope.
And she painted this
over the next few days,
and it went up around Tuesday morning.
And it was like birds flying into windows.
(laughs) People just stopped,
or they just kept walking
and walked into the window.
They were so mesmerized,
they bumped into each
other on the sidewalk.
And these are still there.
These windows, I think,
will be there forever.
And I just love the idea
that 35 years from now,
there will be teenagers
inside that Starbucks,
looking at the reverse image and saying,
"What the heck is that in the window?"
They're sipping their Frappuccinos.
They don't know about the shooting.
And somebody, some old
hand inside this Starbucks
will explain to them why these words
and images are in the Starbucks window.
I took this photograph,
which is why it's terrible.
I'm a poor photographer.
Composition is bad.
This is the sign off the highway
as you drive up Forward Avenue
to the base of Murray,
and enter Squirrel Hill.
And if you look at the H in Squirrel Hill,
you'll see a little Star of
David is hanging from it,
a little glitter paper Star of David.
This is one of thousands
of Stars of David,
very small, a few inches across,
that had been handmade and collected
from around the world.
Some were made of Popsicle sticks.
Some were made as school projects
out of cut paper.
Some were knit or crocheted
or macramed or papier-mached, you name it.
And they were collected
through a Facebook group
that then, in November,
went around and hung them
all over the city, from signs,
from statuary, from trees.
And most of them didn't last the winter
because of the weather, but, of course,
in the winter, you
could look up sometimes,
if you were on Forbes Avenue, let's say,
and there'd be a light snow.
And the street lamps
would be reflecting off the snow
and then off of these stars.
And it was as if the
stars were representing
the dead, as if there
were thousands of angels
in the sky above the streets.
It was just so beautiful.
This was the last one I saw.
In March, it was still hanging there.
And I would always check
when I was driving into town,
is that star still there?
And then the next week
after I took this photo, it wasn't there.
It was on the ground in the mud.
And I found it. I have it.
But it was kind of a
worldwide project, right?
So all of a sudden, there's a kind
of homely Hamish public art
created around the world
that ends up decorating
Squirrel Hill in Pittsburgh,
which I just think is a
kind of beautiful effect
and very, very, very contemporary.
I include this photograph just because
it's important to note that
there were Orthodox Jews
walking with the hearse
of one of the victims on
the way to the interment.
None of the victims was Orthodox,
and yet a lot of the people who helped
with the grieving
process, in various ways,
acting as shomrim, for example, as guards
over the bodies, in some
cases cleansing the bodies,
performing the ritual of Tahara,
were Orthodox, and that kind
of not just interreligious cooperation,
but intrareligious
cooperation, is quite rare.
One of the interesting things I found
is that Squirrel Hill
has a very unusual level
of amity amongst the different
Jewish denominations,
which is something
that really does bear further study.
Another thing that happens
after a mass killing
is a lot of money comes in.
Some of it is raised
by quasi-official organizations,
in this case, the Jewish
Federation of Greater Pittsburgh,
but some of it is raised
by solo operators.
This is Shay Khatiri, an
ex-Muslim Iranian expatriate
now living inside the
Beltway down in Washington,
doing a master's at one
of the Johns Hopkins programs in DC.
He woke up that morning.
He heard what had happened.
He was sick to his stomach.
He went to a local coffee shop
and opened up a gofundme.org page
to raise money.
And within a few days,
it had raised $1.5 million
for the Jews of Squirrel,
well, for Tree of Life
and the victims' families and so forth,
for the congregations and the families,
making him, I think,
probably the largest single fundraiser,
non-Jewish fundraiser,
for the Jewish community
of Squirrel Hill ever.
When I asked him to
provide a photo of himself,
he sent me this picture of himself
standing in front of the White House
holding Plato's "Republic,"
which I think tells you
about how he sees himself
and his commitment to
Western civilization,
and wanting to be part
of the American project.
A group of teenagers,
seniors at Taylor Allderdice High School,
the big public high
school in Squirrel Hill,
gathered at that Starbucks to organize
a vigil that night.
It happened six or seven hours
after the crime scene was secured.
And it was a Havdalah ritual,
the ritual that brings out the Sabbath
that ends Saturday.
And here you could see Emily Pressman
holding the Havdalah candle,
an observant Jewish girl, woman.
She's in college now.
They were high school seniors at the time.
To the right of her is Isabel Smith,
who was a classmate of hers at Allderdice.
African American, biracial,
ancestrally Christian,
though she told me she's
not particularly religious.
And it gives you a sense
of the interfaith nature,
again, of the healing.
What these girls did,
along with some boys,
was pull out several thousand people
to the heart of the Squirrel
Hill commercial district
within a few hours.
They had planned the whole thing.
They got stages, they got a
guitarist, they got candles,
they got amplification system, everything.
And here at six or seven p.m., at dusk,
you see the crowds
at the corners of Forbes and Murray.
And what's important,
you could see their umbrellas out.
That day, there was rain off and on.
What's really interesting
is what you don't see.
The photograph is taken
from the steps of Sixth
Presbyterian Church,
which, for 40 years,
was the church of Mister
Rogers, Fred Rogers.
As all good Pittsburghers
know, Mister Rogers
was a Pittsburgher.
He taped the show
at the public TV station
just down the road from Squirrel Hill.
Actually, I actually think
it's in Squirrel Hill.
It's technically not the
Oakland neighborhood yet.
There's a lotta controversy over that.
People will typically call it Oakland,
but I think it's still in Squirrel Hill.
And Mister Rogers was one
of the great local allies
to the Jews.
A religious Presbyterian,
an ordained minister, in fact, who,
when he set out to create
a fictional neighborhood,
"Mister Rogers' Neighborhood,"
that represented a world in which children
could play and feel safe
and give free rein to their imagination,
he looked out the window of his house
and what he saw was Squirrel Hill,
which is where he lived.
And so literally, this is
Mister Rogers' neighborhood,
and this photograph is
taken from the steps
of his church.
The president came.
Politicians do tend to come
to mass killings, if
they are deadly enough,
(laughs) which is a
rather macabre discussion.
At what point do you qualify
for a presidential visit?
Not at four or five dead,
but certainly at 11 dead.
Some people, as I discussed,
didn't want President Trump to come,
but ultimately, Rabbi
Myers of Tree of Life
felt that it was his
job to offer hospitality
to anyone who came, and he welcomed
the president and first lady,
and talked to them for about 20 minutes
inside the building.
Here they are outside the building.
And you can see at waist level,
Greg Zanis' Crosses for Losses
with the Stars of David
and people's names on the front.
You can see Sylvan Simon, Bernice Simon,
Daniel Stein and Melvin Wax
all inscribed on those stars.
There was an anti-Trump protest.
Thousands of people attended that.
In fact, somebody said to me
they thought that the anti-Trump protest
was the single largest gathering of Jews
in one place in Pittsburgh history,
which is probably true.
It was probably more Jews
than ever had gathered
in one synagogue building
for Rosh Hashanah or Yom
Kippur or anything else.
It was massive.
To express their anger at Trump,
they performed a kind of makeshift
keriah ritual.
Those of you who know the
rituals of Jewish mourning
know that you often rend a garment
when you hear that a loved one has died.
And in modernity, instead
of rending the garment,
often people will affix a black ribbon
to their outfit, and then
tear the black ribbon.
So to express their
grief and anger at Trump,
what they did, what the organizers did,
was hand out thousands
of pieces of black paper.
And then when they gave the signal,
everyone went quiet and
held the black paper
up to the sky and tore it all at once.
So you just heard the tearing,
as if there were a rend in
the fabric of the universe
at the anti-Trump protest.
Now, not everyone was so subtle.
There were some angrier gestures,
but those were pretty rare.
And, in fact, the protest
was overwhelmingly peaceful.
There was one arrest,
and it was an arrest of someone
who was being quite nonviolent.
This is University of Pittsburgh
sociology professor Joshua Bloom,
the only person arrested at the protest.
He sat down in front of Trump's motorcade
and began meditating and chanting
and praying and singing.
And the police took him away.
He emphasized to me when I interviewed him
that the police were
quite gentle with him,
and he was released the next day
and no charges were pressed.
Celebrities come in the
aftermath of a mass killing.
Here you can see another
president and first lady.
That's Tom Hanks,
perhaps the most popular American ever.
He has his arm around Mister
Rogers' widow, Joanne Rogers.
This is at a memorial for the dead,
I believe in December, a couple months
after the killing.
Now, this is interesting because,
those of you who are football fans
will recognize that
lustrous head of white hair.
It's Robert Kraft, the owner
of the New England Patriots.
And one of the things that
happens after a mass killing
is when people come to town,
they wanna pay their respect.
So Robert Kraft, who grew up
in an observant Jewish home,
did come to worship with Tree of Life
the Saturday before the Sunday
on which his Patriots
were to play the Steelers.
Tree of Life was, by the way, not in use,
and still isn't in use.
The congregations are
all worshiping elsewhere.
So this came after services
at Rodef Shalom Temple,
which is where Tree of Life has relocated
and rented space there.
But what's interesting, of course,
is you'll notice that the owner
of the New England Patriots
is wearing the Pittsburgh Steelers
Stronger Than Hate yarmulke.
And it struck me, this is the first time
probably in world history
that the owner of one AFC NFL team
has worn the garb of a rival team,
but he did it, for obvious reasons.
He was in the house of the Steelers,
and he put it on.
And although I don't
normally take photographs
on the Sabbath, I felt like God
wanted me to take out my iPhone
and surreptitiously snap
a photo of Robert Kraft,
Patriots owner, wearing Steelers garb.
Funny stuff in the
aftermath of a mass killing.
Dogs come from hundreds of miles away,
if not more.
Therapy dogs, support dogs.
People who believe that their animals
will help people heal.
I talked to one woman from New Jersey
who brought a bunch of dogs
many, many hours to Pittsburgh.
I don't know whose dogs these were,
but you see them wearing the red vest
that indicate they're some
sort of support animals.
And you see this girl petting the dogs
and holding a note she had written
for the local police.
If you squint, you can
see that the note says
thank you for keeping the Jews
in my neighborhood safe.
Lily, age six.
I'm a dog person, and I choke up
every time I see this photograph.
And finally, I just wanna show you
a picture of the charming
and handsome Robert Zacharias,
who became a friend of mine,
holding out a challah that he made.
The picture was taken by
his girlfriend, Molly.
They are lovely people whose company
I really got to enjoy.
And I wanna tell you something
about Robert Zacharias.
So just take a look at him,
take a look at his beautiful punim
and his nice smile and countenance.
And then I wanna read you
a bit from the epilogue of my book.
I wanna conclude by reading to you
this bit about Robert Zacharias,
who changed something about himself
as a result of the killing.
And in the next three minutes,
you're gonna learn why.
The morning of the shooting,
Zach, as he is known,
had been hanging with a
friend at her apartment
in the Bloomfield neighborhood,
northwest of Squirrel Hill.
After hearing about the
killing, Zach went home.
He checked in with his family and friends,
and a couple hours
later, in mid-afternoon,
he went to the Giant Eagle supermarket
to buy soup and Yahrzeit candles,
small candles one lights
to honor the dead.
Before he left,
he dug into his closet
for one of the yarmulkes.
He put it on and left for the market.
It was the first time
he'd ever worn a yarmulke
when it wasn't Shabbat or a Jewish holiday
or some other special occasion.
He kept the yarmulke on his
head at the Havdalah event
planned by the high school students,
and he has been wearing one ever since.
"It is a new experience for me
"to be wearing a yarmulke
"out in the world on a regular basis,"
Zach said to me.
"It has these interesting implications."
He mentioned a night when
he and his girlfriend
had been trying to decide
where to go out and eat.
I was like, "Well, Gooski's is open."
And then I thought,
wait, I heard they have
some Nazis at Gooski's.
Zach was referring to the rumor that,
at some point, some sort
of Neo-Nazi punk band
had played a gig at Gooski's,
a little dive bar in their
Polish Hill neighborhood.
Zach figured that the
rumor was probably false,
but his head was spinning
with possibility.
He thought about the
overlap between punks,
some of whom lived in Polish Hill,
and various strains of
white nationalist ideology.
And he realized that
if there were neo-Nazis
hanging out at Gooski's,
he now looked like a target.
"But I didn't wanna take my yarmulke off
"to go to Gooski's and
have dinner," he said.
"That didn't feel right.
"That's some kind of
bizarre paying of obeisance
"to the ghost or not ghost Nazis,
"and I don't wanna do that,
but I also don't wanna not go
"to Gooski's if I wanna go
to some neighborhood bar
"that has vegan kielbasa."
The yarmulke, Zach realized,
complicated everything.
If he took it off, the neo-Nazis,
real or imagined, would win.
If he kept it on, but skipped Gooski's,
the neo-Nazis, real or imagined,
would have deprived him
of tasty vegan kielbasa.
But if he said yes to the
yarmulke and to Gooski's,
then he might be putting
his visibly Jewish self
in sight of the real
or imaginary neo-Nazis.
Now, to be clear, there is no evidence,
actually, that neo-Nazis
ever hung out at Gooski's.
I did the research on
this, pure urban legend.
Anyway, Zach weighed his options,
screwed up his courage and took himself
and his girlfriend to Gooski's.
And when he stepped inside,
he took a look around and thought,
these aren't antisemites here.
He saw a co-worker of his at the bar
reading "The New York
Times" app on his iPhone
as he drank a beer and smoked a cigarette.
It was all copacetic at Gooski's.
But the yarmulke was not
finished with him yet.
He and his girlfriend sat at the bar
and placed their orders.
"I made a very expensive
order by mistake,"
Zach told me, "and then I was like,
"oh, I shouldn't get that."
He turned away from the
bar to look his menu,
to figure out what to order instead.
But as he turned away,
he noticed the bartender
looking at his yarmulke,
and then he was immediately concerned
that she would see him changing his order
as a manifestation of his Jewishness.
I was like, "Oh, God damn it.
"Now I'm a money-grubbing Jew.
"Like, I'm complaining
about the expensive order
"and adjusting my order
to be less expensive.
"So I felt bad about that
"because now I'm some sort of symbol
"of all the Jews.
"I'm the standard-bearer
for all these people
"whom I don't bear a
standard for," he recalled.
Zach was still feeling
like the guy in a yarmulke
who had flagged a problem with his tab
when something happened
to compound his misery.
He lifted his bottle of
Yuengling beer to his mouth
to have a sip, and a bit sloshed out
and landed on a man sitting
next to him at the bar.
It was just a tiny bit of beer,
and it seemed the man didn't notice,
so Zach elected not to say anything.
I thought, oh, he doesn't
notice, doesn't matter.
But no sooner had Zach elected
to let the matter drop
than the man turned around.
He had noticed.
Zach quickly apologized,
tried to make everything
right, but it was too late.
I was like, "I'm sorry.
"I spilled some beer,"
but I hadn't said it
when I spilled the beer.
So yet again, I think, now I'm a jerk,
a selfish, unapologetic Jew person.
So it's even worse. Everything is bad.
Zach threw his hands up in despair.
It seems that a public Jew can never win.
So I like ending on that one
because it sort of tells you
how far-reaching the ramifications
of a mass killing are, right?
11 people go to synagogue on Shabbat
to three different congregations
inside one building.
A white nationalist antisemite,
fueled principally by
anti-immigrant sentiment,
and we can talk about his motivations,
if you want, enters the building
and murders 11 people
and wounds two others,
and then wounds several
of the police who respond.
And then as you look at what happens
over the next day and the next week
of sitting shiva and
the month of Sheloshim
and the whole year of
mourning, you discover
that dogs come and a medical clown
from Israel comes to clown for people.
And a guy living a
neighborhood or two over
starts wearing a yarmulke.
And a woman named Lynn Hyde
living in the downtown district
hears the sirens go by
on the way to Tree of Life.
And when she finds out what happens,
she makes the decision, finally,
to convert to Judaism,
something she'd been
thinking about for years.
And an African American
woman named Rose McGee,
living outside of Minneapolis,
decides to bake pies
for the victims' families
and the congregations.
And then thinks, I believe the Jews
have some dietary laws,
and she ends up asking
the local Jewish day school,
the Jewish elementary school,
can I use your kitchen to
bake my sweet potato pies?
Because I want them to be kosher,
and I understand I need
to use a special kitchen.
And then ends up baking the pies there,
the first kosher pies she's ever made,
and then flying them to Pittsburgh
to give them to people.
You end up seeing these sort
of endless concentric circles
of helping and healing and loving.
And what I argue implicitly in this book
is that those end up happening much more
it they are facilitated
by a certain kind of neighborhood,
a neighborhood that is
both geographically dense,
diverse and pluralistic,
not just between Jews
and non-Jews, but of
different kinds of Jews,
that has many, many
multi-generational families.
I kept meeting people who'd
grown up in Squirrel Hill,
left, and then moved back there.
People who were third-
and fourth-generation Squirrel Hill people
and so forth, so on.
That basically everything about
the urbanist structure
of this specific
neighborhood offered lessons
about how you could
imagine a community that,
should something terrible happen,
would not only be able to survive,
but, in some senses, to thrive,
and that's what the book is about.
So thank you very much.
- Wow, Mark, thank you so much.
That was just really great.
And you have such
an amazing talent to
capture people's words,
and even your performance of them
was just really
- Thank you.
- Spectacular, so thank you.
So a bunch of questions.
And I urge everybody to please use
the Q and A function
at the bottom of your screen.
So
a few questions that are coming in,
just to say more about,
and I'll maybe ask you a few,
a couple questions
together and let you riff.
- Sure.
- More about the neighborhood.
So about the specificity
of the neighborhood.
How, you kind of referred
to this at the beginning,
just unusual Squirrel Hill is
as a neighborhood.
And one of my colleagues
points out that she lived
in the Squirrel Hill area as a postdoc
in the 1990s.
That the Jewish presence
was really noticeable,
as was, she remembers, a WPA mural
from the Depression in the post office
of Squirrel Hill
that shows a rabbi.
And how struck she was,
and how unusual is that,
to actually have in a public civil
(Mark laughs)
building, a kind
of representation of Jewishness like that.
- Yeah, well, thank you for that.
I have a number of thoughts.
First of all, I actually never,
I either never went in and saw
or never noticed or
took note of that mural.
There are a lot of WPM
murals in post offices.
I'm sure this has been written about.
Where I live in New Haven, in Westville,
we have a WPA mural in our post office.
And one of the reasons
why we periodically fight
to save the post office,
when they decide to try to save money
by shutting it down, is because
it is so artistically
significant, I think.
- Here, I can share, actually, my screen.
She actually helpfully sent it.
So let me see-
- Fabulous.
- [Maurice] Work for one second.
- It would not be surprising
that in the '30s already,
that there would have been
people taking note of the Jewish presence
in Squirrel Hill because,
as I said from the beginning,
it was a very religiously
integrated community
with a strong Jewish minority.
The Jews at that point were typically
either in Allegheny City or
they were in East Liberty.
They were in other neighborhoods.
And Pittsburgh was spreading east,
and Squirrel Hill was one
of the easternmost outposts.
And it was hilly and it was nice.
It initially had been very tough to settle
because it's a hill, and the trains
that would carry coal and
other kind of commodities
that a neighborhood needs, initially,
the streetcars couldn't make it up
all the hills of Squirrel Hill.
And so you needed some
technological advances
before it could be well-settled.
And then in the late, I think in the 1890s
or around 1900, they
started to develop it.
It was land purchased
by Gentile developers.
It was not as if Jews
said, "Let's settle here,"
but it quickly became popular with Jews,
and has stayed that way.
Another note that I wanna make
before I answer the question
a bit more substantively
is that everywhere I go,
I now have this magical superpower
of bringing out ex-Pittsburghers,
who are drawn to this in a way
that I don't think that
if I'd written a book
on Cleveland or Omaha,
that I would bring out
Clevelanders and Omahavians.
But the Pittsburgh diaspora
is exceedingly loyal.
People who've spent
even a year or two there
think of themselves as
having lived in Pittsburgh,
and it's meaningful to them.
One thing I would note
is that if it sometimes
seems to be the case
that everyone knows
someone who used to live
in Pittsburgh, that's
partly because everyone
does know someone who used
to live in Pittsburgh.
Pittsburgh has a tremendously
populous diaspora
because it only has 1/2 the population
that it had 50 years ago.
So the world is filled with people
who left Pittsburgh, because for a while,
its economy cratered and everyone left.
And now it is thriving again,
but it's a different size city.
So it's not accidental
that everywhere I go,
there are people who used
to live in Pittsburgh,
in a way that there
aren't, everywhere I go,
people who used to live my hometown
of Springfield, Massachusetts.
From the very beginning,
there was an Orthodox presence,
which I think is significant
in that the infrastructure
that a neighborhood has often comes
from the Orthodox, in
terms of building a mikvah,
a ritual bath, in terms of some shops.
That might be a kosher butcher,
that might be a Jewish baker.
In terms of the fact
that you will build up a
neighborhood differently
if it has to be hospitable
to Sabbath-observant Jews.
You can't be too far-flung
if you're expecting people to walk a mile
or two or less on Saturday
to get to their synagogue.
So neighborhoods that cater to
and welcome observant Jews,
Sabbath-observant Jews,
are inherently built for density,
which is why neighborhoods
like West Rogers Park
in Chicago and Squirrel Hill
and Westville in New Haven
are often such lovely, properly sized,
human-scale neighborhoods.
I mean, that's not accidental.
They also have to have
really interesting zoning
because you have to be zoned
for residential properties,
but you also have to
allow houses of worship.
And you probably have to allow
some commercial properties, as well,
because people are gonna
wanna be able to walk,
especially if they're
having large families,
they're gonna wanna walk to their butcher,
their baker, their candlestick maker.
So they tend to be neighborhoods
that resist the suburbanization
and the kind of strip
mall-ification of America
better than most neighborhoods.
You simply can't do Jewish
life on those models.
You have to do it on a more
old-fashioned urbanist model.
And then Squirrel Hill
also has another advantage,
and I don't fully understand why.
People have lots of
different theories about why
it ended up working so well,
but it also has many
different sizes of housing.
I make the point in my book that you
can get into the Taylor
Allderdice school district
for under $200,000 or over a million.
I mean, it has apartments.
It has townhouses.
It has three-family houses.
It has mansions.
And so it just developed
really, really beautifully.
But the most important
thing about Squirrel Hill
as a neighborhood
is that there was a key, pivotal moment
when Jews were heading to the suburbs,
in the '60s and '70s and '80s,
as Americans do when they have the money,
Americans of all ethnicities.
And the Jewish establishment decided not
to move the institutions
of the establishment to the suburbs.
So unlike, say, New Haven
and most other American places
where they moved the
Jewish community center
and the day school to
the first-ring suburb,
in Pittsburgh, they decided to raise money
to rebuild and refurbish
all those institutions
right in Squirrel Hill.
And that was a very brave decision.
There's a man named Howard Rieger,
who was very instrumental in that,
who now lives in Chicago
and is a real urbanist activist there.
And there had to be, on
top of all of those aspects
of good fortune, there also
had to be some intentionality.
And so a lot came together really well.
- Great.
Okay, I was not able to share my screen,
but-
- That's okay.
- Can Google the mural in the post office.
Okay, so a kind of broader question here.
It strikes me, listening to your talk,
that there are really
like two competing
narratives going on here.
There's the one that this is a time
of the worst antisemitic attack
in American history.
That was not the only one.
As we know, there have been other ones,
including just a couple weeks ago.
But then, also, you really put
this emphasis on coming together
and people showing up for Jews.
So the competing narrative
would be that Jews have,
in fact, never been more
integrated into American life,
possibly into any culture's life,
than they are now.
- Right.
- So how do you think about
those two competing narratives,
and how does Squirrel Hill, what happened,
help us think about them?
- Yeah.
I recently wrote a piece for
"The Wall Street Journal"
in which I pointed out
that social antisemitism
of the kind that kept
Jews out of country clubs
or out of partnerships
at certain law firms,
as far as I can tell, is
completely gone in America.
I'm sure there are last
vestiges somewhere.
And I've often said on my podcast,
"If anyone knows of a country club
"that truly blackballs Jews
"or a law firm that truly
won't make a Jewish partner,
"let me know 'cause I
wanna break that story,"
but I don't think they exist,
except as urban legend, anymore.
So social antisemitism of the kind
that my grandparents would have feared
is basically gone, which is great.
And that is not necessarily
the case in all,
say, Western European countries.
For example, my British and French friends
tell me there is a lot of
social antisemitism there,
in the academy and elsewhere.
At the same time,
things have gotten more violent
over the past 10 years for Jews.
Principally, those being attacked are Jews
who either look visibly Jewish
because of what they
wear as observant Jews,
or Jews who enter any Jewish space.
Whether they are highly
observant themselves or not,
they've had the courage
to send their children
to Jewish day schools
or to go to synagogue
or to play squash at the
Jewish community center.
And the second you enter a Jewish space,
you are making yourself a target.
Some people misread my
piece to be counseling Jews
to just not enter Jewish spaces.
I mean, it was a very
interesting litmus test
of how people read it,
because I got a lot of mail saying,
"Why are you telling us
to just assimilate more
"and not enter Jewish spaces?"
And I thought to myself, no, no, no.
I'm one of those Jews
who goes to Jewish spaces
all the time, and I'm saying
we're the ones who are
potentially being victimized.
That doesn't make us better or worse.
It's just a sociological fact
that that's where you'll
find the antisemitism now.
I also got a lot of pushback from people
who said, "Well, but then
there's a big exception
"of college campuses,
where there does seem
"to be rising antisemitism."
And far-right and far-left
politics have targeted
a lot of Jews and made
a lot of Jews afraid
of being proudly Jewish
or speaking about Zionism
in the ways they want
and so forth and so on.
And I think that's very real.
So what you saw in Squirrel Hill,
you see a kind of amity,
a kind of absence of social antisemitism
and an absence of social suspicion,
that meant that the Gentile
allies and neighbors
really rushed to help Jews.
And, indeed, the police
rushed to help Jews.
And that's a very important fact,
that for most of Jewish history,
it's like this in "Fiddler on the Roof,"
God bless and keep the czar
far away from me, right?
Like, agents of the state generally come
to either draft you into the czar's army
or smash your businesses or murder you.
And this was the case in
which agents of the state came
and put their bodies in
between Jews and bullets.
And that's a very important
fact about America today,
that the agents of the
state are on our side.
But this is a time in which
there have been more violent
attacks on synagogues
and on, more numerous, still,
non-lethal but still violent attacks
on Orthodox Jews on the
streets of Brooklyn,
for example, than in any other five-
or 10-year period I can think of.
My general sense is that in a country
of 330 million people,
they are statistically meaningless.
The odds that any given
Jew is going to be punched
or shot are very, very low,
and I don't walk around
with any anxiety about it myself.
However, what they do in terms of the mood
and the fearfulness
and the way they provide a litmus test
about how much do Gentiles
react is significant.
So, for example, I
think there's definitely
an anti-Jewish bias in a
lot of the mainstream media.
If you look at the way that Collegeville,
Colleyville was reported in Texas,
it got far less attention
than it would have
if a different, if any
different minority group
had been held hostage in
their house of worship.
There's just no question
that Jews don't count as much
at many media outlets.
So it's very complicated.
- And to follow up on what you were saying
about the Orthodox,
it strikes me that there
are constant attacks
on Orthodox Jews now.
I mean, I just read about more this week.
And there is not that
same kumbaya (laughs)
kind of outpouring of,
I mean, or much less
than it seemed-
- No, there's not.
And, indeed.
- Yeah.
(crosstalk)
- And not even from other Jews.
I mean, the real shonda,
the real shame there
is what I see as the secular
and liberal Jewish willingness to throw
our more observant brethren and sistren,
if that a word, under the bus.
That when it's Haredi, black-hatted Jews
and their wives being
punched and kicked
and attacked verbally and physically
in Borough Park,
that less observant and more acculturated
and assimilated Jews several miles away
don't care that much.
Is that antisemitism?
I mean, yeah, there's some self-loathing,
there's some shame.
I mean, the anti-Orthodox animus
among many non-Orthodox
Jews is profound and deep.
It exists in my own family.
And we're a family
of non-Orthodox Jews, for the most part.
All Jews have some
relatives who are Orthodox.
And I think that that's
an internal conversation
that we have to deal with,
but there's a way in which
the visibly Jewish Jews
are lightning rods who draw a lot
of the violence away, a lot
of the physical violence,
away from the rest of us,
and we have to think about that.
- Yeah.
So a question
from someone in the audience
who's a grad student
who grew up in Squirrel Hill,
and really appreciates
the relative integration
of different denominations.
And question is how can
other Jewish communities
learn or build on Squirrel Hill's example?
- That's a great question.
I mean, the first thing I always wanna say
is that I'm always wary
of making prescriptions
or normative claims
about how Jews ought to be,
unless those Jews are my children,
in which case I'm all about ideas
for how they should be. (laughs)
I have nothing but ways
to hector my own kids.
But other people's
kids, I try to back off.
So I'm a journalist
and a lapsed historian,
so I try to just say things how they are.
It's not my job to tell
people what they ought to do.
I will say
that, inevitably, my role,
my feelings as a Jew and as a citizen
definitely are inescapable,
especially in a project like this.
And I guess there would
be one basic lesson,
which is to practice
what I see Squirrel Hill Jews practicing,
which is a kind of intrafaith solidarity.
That Squirrel Hill's
remarkable for the extent
to which secular, Reform,
Reconstructionist,
Conservative Jews know each other
and know the orthodox.
And I make the point that you'll find
a Chabad rebbetzin power walking
with a Reformed Jewish woman
on a Shabbat afternoon.
And you'll find non-Orthodox Jews
at the Shabbat tables
of Orthodox Jews on Friday nights.
Just the level of knowledge
and the way in which
they're in each other's
lives in Squirrel Hill,
partly because of the
intergenerational nature of it.
Like, I would meet Orthodox who said,
"Well, my grandpa was Reform,
"but two generations later,
I've gotten more observant,"
but they stayed in Squirrel
Hill the whole time.
So the family ties go back very deep.
I would just say
you practice hospitality and make sure
it's a hospitality towards Jews
who are not like you,
as well as Jews who are.
It's very simple, but
it's very hard to do.
And most of us, including me,
fall down on the job.
- Yeah.
So a question about
what people have done in Squirrel Hill,
but also maybe just more generally,
to counter the source of the tragedy,
which is the resurgence
of white nationalism,
and even outright Nazism.
Can you say a little bit more?
- I mean, on the very kind of basic level,
there are security measures,
that most synagogues now have a guard.
We didn't used to mostly have a guard.
My synagogue now has a guard.
I am a skeptic about how much
that would matter if a well-armed person
wanted to come and kill Jews.
I think it might not matter much.
The guard might just be the first person
to get shot, after which
it might be open season.
I've talked to a lot of
friends who have other ideas
about what security would work,
rather than a kind of security theater
that I think we now have, which, often,
by the way, proves very expensive.
A lot of money is being wasted
on bogus security measures right now.
But
in terms of how to counter the ideology,
I don't think Jews can counter.
I don't think anyone.
I mean, Jews can't fix antisemites.
Antisemites are soul-sick people,
and they're not reacting to Jews
and they're not reacting to Israel.
And they're not reacting to immigration.
Because to even go down
that line of thinking,
I think, suggests that
there's a kind of rationale
to antisemitism.
There is, of course, an
internal logic to it.
In their own brains, it makes some sense.
But irrational bigotry
defeats that kind of.
I mean, it's like cult deprogramming.
Can it be done?
Sure, but it's extremely
labor-intensive. (laughs)
I mean, people should go
read the terrific book,
Eli Saslow's book "Rising Out of Hatred,"
about the former Klansman Derek Black,
who went to New College of Florida,
where he ended up leaving.
He'd been raised in a kind of Klan family,
a very prominent Klan family.
Again, the book is Saslow, S-A-S-L-O-W,
and it's called "Rising
Out of Hatred," I think.
He's a "Washington Post" reporter.
Best book I've read.
And you can give it to an 11-year-old.
Like, it reads very easily.
And my daughter's read it.
Totally gripping.
And this guy went off to college.
For some reason, he went
to a fairly progressive
liberal arts college.
And some Jews started inviting
him to Shabbat dinner.
And that's actually what cured him
of his antisemitism,
was just knowing Jews.
So I think we have to
practice more hospitality
to all humans, but we
should do that, anyway,
because it's a mitzvah
that we're called on to do.
I don't think we can worry much about how
to cure antisemites.
- Okay, great.
Well, that brings us
exactly to the end of our program.
So I just want to thank you so much.
On behalf of everyone who you can't see,
who I'm sure are, they're all
silently clapping at home,
(Mark laughs)
thank you.
I urge everyone to buy the book.
And, really, thank you again, Mark.
It was really a fascinating discussion.
- Well, you and the community around you
have been a huge source of support,
and I'm excited to meet everyone in person
when that's possible.
So thanks, again.
- Exactly.
Okay, and thank you to everyone
who showed up.
Bye-bye.